[Music]
my next guest
is on a us tour that brings him to the
hollywood bowl on october 5th tonight
he's here to perform i won't give up
from his latest album love is a
four-letter word to see a special bonus
performance from the album head over to
teamcoco.com
summer music please welcome back our
good friend jason mraz
even if the skies
get
[Music]
and when you're needing your
space
to do some navigating
i'll be here patiently waiting
[Music]
to see what you find
cause even
[Music]
god knows we're worth it
[Music]
no
i won't give up
[Music]
i don't want to be someone who walks
away so easily i'm here to stay and make
the difference that i can make
our differences they do a lot to teach
us how to use the tools and gifts we got
here we got
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who i
[Applause]
give
am
on
us
even if the skies
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
i won't give up
[Music]
[Music]
that was great
thank you so much good to see you again
jason ross ladies and gentlemen